[Musique]
les astrophysiciens situe la formation
de la terre il y à plus de 4 56
milliards d'années la terre était alors
une masse de gaz et de matière en fusion
il aurait ensuite fallu un demi milliard
d'années pour que cette soupe
biochimiques se met en place se
stabilise et permettent l'apparition des
premières molécules qui vont favoriser
les premières signe de vie terrestre
la première manifestation de la plus
ancienne manifestation
retrouvez sur terre par des géologues
est un fragment de sédiments marins qui
contenait les bactéries ces bactéries
sont considérés aujourd'hui comme nous
plus ancêtres comme nos plus vieux
ancêtres en termes d'évolution
biologique et cette problématique des
bactéries vous l'avez deviné c'est un
peu mon dada
pourquoi les bactéries ces bactéries
sont des micro organismes que l'on va
retrouver partout sur notre corps
l'ensemble de ces micro-organismes
forment ce qu'on va appeler le
microbiote ce microbiote est présent non
seulement en nous mais également sur
nous
ce microbiote et donc je suis désolé un
petit problème technique mais j'ai
continué ce microbiote est donc présent
à différentes localisations et les
techniques de biologie moléculaire ont
permis en fait de décrire de comprendre
et de comparer ces différents microbiote
et on distingue actuellement on connaît
au niveau des microbes de cumin le
microbiote nasale orale le microbiote
cutanée gastro intestinales ou encore
vaginale ce microbiote se met en place
très tôt dès la naissance voire même
avant et la manière dont ce microbiote
se met en place est une étape clip pour
chacun d'entre nous dans notre vie
puisqu'elle va conditionner et
conditionnerait notre statut santé en
effet c'est microbiote on sait que
aujourd'hui ils peuvent être très
différents c'est ce que vous avez par
exemple ici présentés entre le
microbiote intestinal ou encore le
microbiote orale qui est en orange de
l'eau gastro intestinal qui est en bleu
ils peuvent être également très
semblables c'est le cas par exemple du
microbiote plus tanniques est en verre
et du microbiote nasal qui est en rouge
assez microbiote on sait qu'ils sont
également composés par différents types
de bactéries mais également une quantité
différentes et variable de bactéries ce
qu'est ce que vous avez représenté comme
exemple ici du microbiote cutanées
chaque commentaire vous voyez qu'il ya
des couleurs
chaque couleur est une bactérie
différentes et les tares de chaque comme
ambert correspondent au quartier des
camemberts correspondent à cette
quantité de bactéries donc que nous
sommes que nous soyons jeunes vieux
hommes femmes
nous vivons tous avec des bactéries en
nous et sur nous et ces bactéries
elle nous apporte un certain nombre de
fonctionnalités biologique
par exemple les corps et les bactéries
que vous retrouvez sur notre peau au
niveau des aisselles son responsable en
partie de votre odeur corporelle et la
prochaine fois vous serez dans les
transports en commun en pleine période
d'été est que quelqu'un peut vous faire
une remarque peut-être désagréable
vous pourrez lui dire c'est pas de ma
faute ce sont mes corinne et bactéries
donc vous l'avez donc les bactéries et
le microbiote les bactéries qui
participent ou microbiote de chacun
d'entre nous ont des fonctionnalités
biologique pour notre organisme
ces fonctionnalités elles peuvent être
communes aux différents microbiote on
les retrouve dans les différents micro
blogs comme par exemple la production
d'énergie les différentes couleurs que
vous voyez sur l'écran correspondent à
différentes bactéries qui sont capables
de réaliser cette fonctions métaboliques
d'autres fonctionnalités sont
spécifiques à certains microbiote c'est
le cas par exemple du microbiote
intestinal dans lequel on va retrouver
un certain nombre de bactéries qui sont
capables de produire de la vitamine k
notre organisme est incapable de le
produire naturellement il a besoin d'une
source de cette vitamine exogènes or
cette vitamine est nécessaire
indispensable pour les processus de
coagulation de notre sens donc vous
l'avez compris le microbiote et les
bactéries qui constitue participent à
notre équilibre physiologique et comme
tout équilibre physiologique
il peut être modifié en fonction des
stimuli qu'il va recevoir ces stimuli
vont en retour du microbiote avoir une
réponse qui peut être positive ou
négative sur notre organisme
donc on peut prendre un autre exemple
qui est un peu plus caractéristique qui
est le fait d'une modification de notre
rythme biologique par exemple pour
prendre un cas concret en effet on est
nous sommes des êtres vivants dits sûrs
avec une activité qui se passe pendant
la journée et pendant la nuit nous
sommes supposés dormir et nous avons un
rythme biologique va considérer pour la
plupart d'entre nous de 24 heures on a
pu constater qu' il y avait également ce
séquentielle qu'on pouvait retrouver au
niveau des bactéries du microbiote
intestinal avec des bactéries qui
étaient présentes uniquement pendant la
période de la journée et qui
disparaissait pendant la nuit de manière
séquentielle et qui suivait donc notre
rythme biologique en prenant comme un
modèle animal comme la souris
et en essayant de décaler ce rythme
biologique de la souris de 8 heures en
gros mais les souris en jet lag et bien
qu est ce qu on a pu constater c'est ce
que vous avez en rouge qui est présenté
sur le graphe on a pu constater qu'on
était capable de modifier complètement
7-5 séquentielle de présence des
bactéries présentes jour et nuit et qui
disparaît complètement
donc maintenant on pourrait aller plus
loin on pourrait imaginer que dans cette
salle on représente une partie du
l'intestin d'un certain monsieur tedx
d'accord tous autant que nous sommes on
va être donc des bactéries potentiel du
microbiote intestinal de monsieur t'ai
dit on sait que ce microbiote qu'il est
composé de différentes bactéries de
bactéries différentes
donc est ce que il ya des personnes dans
la salle qui se prénommerait mari oui
est ce que vous pourriez vous levez s'il
vous plaît est ce que il ya des
personnes qui se prénommerait eric dans
la salle oui vous pouvez vous lever
aussi oui à l'isie allez-y vous avez
vous ne l'a pas pour longtemps
donc vous voyez bien qu'on a des
bactéries des groupes marie des
bactéries du groupe eric ils ont bien
réagi à mon stimuli je leur ai demandé
de se lever
ils se sont levés on est dans le
microbiote on reçoit les informations
les autres sont restés assis on reste
dans un équilibre d'accord merci à vous
de vous être assis vous voyez que de
nouveaux reçoivent à nouveaux stimuli et
de nouveau ils répondent en s'asseyant
et j'ai fait ça rapidement parce que les
personnes qui étaient les bactéries
pardon qui était juste derrière elle
commençait à se dire mai fais ce qu'il
me faut d'accord ils sont gentils mais
moi je ne vois plus rien donc déjà vous
voyez bien que steam lui chacun a plus
la même information d'accord et donc ça
c'était au niveau de ce microbiote là
alors on n'a pas demandé où eric et omar
sy quel était leur activité biologique
dans notre microbiote mais on pourrait
également
on pourrait également recevoir d'autres
stimuli l'accord qui sont extérieurs à
cette salle ou en tout cas à ce qui est
east dans la salle et vous voyez en
effet les lumières se sont mis à
clignoter
c'est plus l'environnement dans lequel
on avait l'équilibré tout à l'heure
d'accord on pourrait encore aller plus
loin c'est à dire que toujours après
cette lumière on pourrait avoir par
exemple
cette fois ci aux deux de clignoter la
lumière qui s'arrête complètement
d'accord et on pourrait continuer comme
ça au niveau du processus jusqu'à
complètement désorganisée l'organisation
qu'on avait initialement dans cette
salle on va pas aller jusqu'à la panique
mais voilà et donc les stimuli qu'on
reçoit vont être vraiment dépendante de
ce qui est au niveau du microbiote et
des bactéries qui sont représentés dans
ce micro min donc toute cette mise en
scène simplement pour vous dire que si
aujourd'hui on connaît le microbiote si
on l'a caractérisé si on lui on peut lui
donner certaines fonctions biologiques
est un élément qui reste encore inconnu
pour nous c'est les voies de
communication et les différents signaux
qui sont utilisés entre le microbiote
vers notre organisme et de notre
organisme vers le microbiote est donc
aujourd'hui en tant que microbiologiste
à travailler maintenant depuis une
quinzaine d'années sur le microbiote je
serais incapable de pouvoir vous dire si
oui ou non il existe un pilote dans le
microbiote mais pour autant je voulais
pas les vous laisser partir sur une
autre note plutôt négative tout
simplement vous dire que je vais
continuer à chercher et que dans un
futur proche on pourra certainement
répondre à cette question
[Applaudissements]